un jour vous découvrez le théâtre vous
aussi c'est à dire qu'un Joal monte vous
montez sur une sur une scène de théâtre
et vous avez une espèce de sensation
comme ça complètement inédite pour vous
une exaltation extraordinaire et vous
dites c'est comme au cinéma quand j'ai
commencé qu'on disait moteur non j'ai
pas dit ça
[Applaudissements]
Bernadette vous êtes très en forme
est-ce qu'on peut dire votre âge
[Musique]
alors Chabrol vous avez demandé de vous
teindre en blond pour l'inspecteur
Lavardin avec Jean Poiret et vous êtes
revenu à une couleur plus plus naturelle
je vois avec avec le temps oh je devrais
rester blonde parce qu'avec tous mes
cheveux blancs je n'aurais besoin de
rien faire
alors heureusement vous avez pas suivi
les conseils d'un autre réalisateur
Jean-Pierre Mocky qui vous avez dit
laisse toi devenir grosse et moche comme
Signoret tu auras plein de boulot bah
non
vous l'avez pas fait vous faites
toujours de la fête toujours de la barre
au sol pas en ce moment mais le théâtre
c'est sportif Muriel
je rappelle que sans alcool la fête est
plus folle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour ça toi tu as pris un musulman comme
ça tu es tranquille il boit pas c'est
mon problème pose tes questions alors
vous dites la forme on travaille et le
moteur de mon existence mon opium ma
cocaïne mon Prozac
oui ah ben oui moi j'aime ça oui j'aime
jouer j'aime jouer oui alors on va
parler de vous on va voir un peu votre
vie qui est assez extraordinaire
[Musique]
ils ont du talent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à Nîmes vos parents étaient protestants
et ils désespéré d'avoir un enfant
malgré 10 ans de vie commune et un jour
ils vont rendre visite à des cousins
dans le Sud-Ouest il s'arrête à Lourdes
et miracle ils avaient fait un voyage
effectivement dans les Pyrénées et puis
en rentrant elle s'est trouvée enceinte
et comme elle voulait avoir un fils j'ai
porté des pantalons sous mes robes
jusqu'à 8 ans quoi et elle m'appelait
Bernard jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
et votre père voulait absolument qu'on
vous fasse pas couper les cheveux parce
qu'il disait quand même pas non plus
c'était magnifique alors effectivement
les amis catholiques de vos parents en
attendant cette histoire de miracle à
Lourdes en redemandait et votre mère
préciser de toute façon catholique nous
avions demandé un garçon
pour les emmerder quant aux protestants
ils y croyaient pas jusqu'en 6ème vous
vivez à Saint-Geniès de Malgoirès
et puis ensuite au lycée de Nîmes votre
père était pharmacien comme tous les
pères de grands réalisateurs de
nouvelles vagues d'ailleurs Chabrol René
rivet
était fou des gens connus et reconnu
il disait ça ça me faisait tellement ça
je comprenait pas il est très admiratif
celui-là il est connu épuisé et reconnu
pour vous c'était le top être connu
pour un meurtre en même temps c'est vrai
donc vous vous étiez folle de Paris
Match la rubrique l ete vous découpiez
des photos de Audrey Hepburn de Silvana
Mangano ryamer
mais tu es un peu déluré déjà vous avez
pas beaucoup de latitude parce que c'est
quand même assez vissé dans la propriété
de vos parents dans les Cévennes vous
aviez une pièce que vous aviez repeinte
en bleu indigo qui était un club privé
qui s'appelait le West and club
c'était le bout du monde
les routes ontlacées pour y arriver elle
s'appelait Anita et Bettina et donc les
garçons dans ce club que vous aviez créé
quoi il venait pas non ouais
parce que vos parents alors ça c'est
incroyable merci mais c'était réduitaire
toute façon ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que les parents c'est vrai les parents
de Bernadette Lafont étaient
en proie à une sexualité int c'est vrai
oui je crois qu'ils sont envoyés bien en
l'air ensemble
c'était une belle histoire de
ses parents c'était les rois de la
sieste crapuleuse ce qu'on appelle dans
le milieu la sieste crapuleuse
c'est-à-dire qu'après déjeuner quand
même c'est trop chaud voilà après des
années
et votre père votre père était un homme
charmant d'ailleurs il traitait votre
mère comme une maîtresse il lui évitait
les tâches domestiques il était très
dévoué à sa femme et leur comme il était
pharmacien il avait des aphrodisiaques
et un jour bernette Lafont a retrouvé
dans un tiroir de la cantaride elle
était périmée
c'est à dire très à cheval sur les
horaires et en même temps vous laissez
vous habiller comme vous voulez c'est
marrant ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous pouviez vous habiller comme une
[ __ ] mais du moment que vous rentriez à
l'heure voilà c'est tout voilà
en plus
vous vous retrouviez comme ça anime
assise seul dans un café on devient
juste au corps si vous êtes on peut le
dire l'inventice du body d'une certaine
façon
comment je faisais de la danse classique
oui et puis on allait se tromper dans la
Méditerranée puis on les laissait sécher
avec tout le sel cette colonne
vous allez mieux
[Applaudissements]
les mecs alors les mecs vous offrez un
singe anneau que vous ne buviez pas
quand même enfin c'était comme ça et
alors ils étaient là en train de vous
raconter des des histoires en train de
vous charmer et vous dites en fait il me
regardait avec un regard de maquignon
qui souplesse la bête mais pourquoi je
faisais ça pour arriver à la question
qu'est-ce que tu fais ou tu habites la
réponse était je fais du cinéma en
Italie en Italie en Italie Sylvana manga
non
vous étiez dépucé à l'âge de 16 ans
voilà l'âge de 16 ans par un dénommé
José qui était coiffeur
et qui buvait de la
nature et qui avait une Lambretta parce
que pour emballer les gonzesses à Nîmes
fait d'avoir la lampe donc alors vous
avez vécu il faut le dire on peut le
dire cette première expérience alors
votre copine Annie elle allait le
pousser des cris formidables c'est lui
plaisait beaucoup vous en fait vous avez
vécu ça un peu comme l'extraction d'une
dent de sagesse
comment ça s'est passé le vôtre
[Applaudissements]
je suis obligé je pose des questions
tellement insensées aux gens que je suis
obligé de répondre quand on me les pose
j'étais disjoqué au whisky à gogo à
Juan-les-Pins et alors il y avait un
disque qui était going home des Rolling
Stones 35 et j'ai profité de séance
minutes parce que vous étiez dit OK
jusqu'à 4h du matin des fois 5 heures
j'ai profité de séance minutes pour
m'enfuir dans la pinède de Juan-les-Pins
qui est en face le wiscago et donc ça a
duré quoi
une éjaculation précoce la première fois
mais un jour je continue l'histoire de
Bernard Lafont mais un jour anime à
l'endroit même où vos parents s'étaient
rencontrés vous rencontrez le cinéma en
la personne de Gérard Blanc en fait tu
connais pas gérable c'était le James in
français alors il était là parce qu'il
était venu répéter une pièce pour les
arènes de Nîmes Jules César avec
armentier et Stéphane Audran il y avait
Gérard léovici on comprend pas trop
pourquoi mais enfin qu'il était de la
figuration et vous les tracteur Gérard
Le beauvices
c'est bizarre comme quoi un autre jeu un
autre jeu ouais et alors donc Gérard
Blanc il faut dire les choses il avait
une voiture noire avec l'intérieur rouge
évidemment ça vous a complètement
séduit alors voilà bon ben limonade
baiser le mariage se profile et alors
évidemment dans Nîmes on commence à
chuchoter elle se marie avec une vedette
de Paris évidemment il y a des jalousies
il y a des lettres de corbeau qui
arrivent chez vos parents
c'est vrai c'est vrai Bernadette il y a
des lettres qui arrivent chez vos
parents bien sûr bien sûr en disant de
toute façon on est enceinte c'est pour
ça qu'elle se marie
n'hésitez pas du tout enceinte un jour
Gérard Blanc vient demander votre main à
vos parents et la première fois je suis
obligé de le dire parce que la première
fois vous faites l'amour avec lui vous
lui faites croire que vous êtes vierge
et je me suis dit si je lui dis que non
il va être tellement vexé ouais je
savais déjà que les hommes étaient
extrêmement chatouilles sur cette
histoire de [ __ ] et donc
c'est vrai
donc voilà vous l'épouser mais lui en
fait est obsédé Bernadette
Bernadette lui est obsédé par le fait
que vous ayez très envie de faire du
cinéma il avait été marié avec Estelle
la Blin c'est pas durer longtemps et
vous disait toi au moins tu es pas comme
toutes ces connes tu veux pas devenir
actrice alors que c'était le rêve de
votre vie en fait
il vous comprenez bien Gérard voilà donc
vous faites quelques photos en maillot
de bain pour mettre du beurre les
épinards parce qu'il est pas non plus
des cachets mirobolants Gérard Blanc et
puis vous rencontrez il vous présente
l'équipe des Cahiers du Cinéma c'était
le début de votre de votre carrière de
mon ascension fulgurante mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai et d'ailleurs vous dites s'il
m'avait présenté Verneuil autant la rage
aurait fait une autre carrière quoi mais
il vous a présenté les gens des Cahiers
du cinéma alors bon à tout citer mais
enfin on va citer les plus grands enfin
les premiers disons présenté en fait on
les a connu et on a tourné les films
ensemble vous avez 157 les mistons de
François Truffaut alors en 59 sorties du
bosserge avec Gérard Blanc un film de
Chabrol 60 les bonnes femmes tu vois
puis voilà puis après bon vous avez fait
tous les grands films de la Nouvelle
Vague on vous a appelé à l'époque la
vente villageoise ça c'était quand le
bossaire est sorti ils ont dit ça ils
ont dit aussi ventes comiques
et alors Hervé Guilbert des années plus
tard vous a appelé la baronnais
avec Hubert voilà vous étiez la petite
fiancée du cinéma français comme on dit
quoi c'était vous et alors vous avez une
explication de la nouvelle vague qui est
absolument extraordinaire vous dites
qu'en fait la Nouvelle Vague c'est parce
qu'on avait inventé une nouvelle
pellicule qui s'appelait La Trix et
qu'en fait on pouvait filmer dehors sans
maquillage et sans lumière ouais c'est
vrai c'était une révolution technique
sinon avant c'était pas possible 5 ans
ou 10 ans avant bien sûr c'est toujours
marrant quand on explique quelque chose
d'artistique en fait par une innovation
technique c'est comme aujourd'hui on
invente des caméras toute petite qui
filment la nuit donc on peut faire des
émissions différentes de celle
voilà et à l'époque vous avez failli
tourner à bout de souffle
oui parce que il voulait Jean Seberg
pour faire le rôle qu'elle a fait
d'ailleurs et il imaginait le père quoi
les garçons la fille donc avec jeans et
Berg c'est des Belmondo et puis comme
Jean Seberg était sous contrat avec
Preminger à Hollywood pour des années il
y avait un moment où c'était compliqué
et ça a failli ne pas se faire et à ce
moment-là moi j'ai tourné à double tour
avec chabrel à Aix-en-Provence et il est
descendu et il m'a dit si je peux pas
avoir Jean donc je change le couple et
est-ce que vous pourriez faire avec
Aznavour
alors Gérard Blanc vous reproche de plus
en plus votre liaison avec le setmar il
est il est jaloux en fait il est jaloux
du fait que vous fassiez du cinéma
Serge c'est moi il vous oblige à dire
que vous aviez 17 ans quand vous en
aviez 19
alors vous vous avez tous les petits
jeux
vous avez sorti
amoureux de moi parce que j'avais 16 ans
et demi et donc il avait pas envie que
j'ai plus
sur ce bouton
vous faites avorter parce que vous dites
d'ailleurs pas question de garder
l'enfant de nos amours des femmes
et puis voilà puis ça se termine comme
ça avec Gérard Blanc et là non ça se
termine pas comme ça parce qu'on est
toujours resté amis toute notre vie et
toujours en servir
on s'entendait beaucoup mieux quand on
était plus ensemble ce que je ne pouvais
pas être la femme qui voulait avoir
c'est à dire une femme qui reste à la
maison elle a trouvé après une femme
voilà et là vous rencontrez durek metzky
alors ça c'est terrible un slave comme
son nom l'indique
hongrois c'est pas cela rien à voir
Madia donc c'était un sculpteur artiste
maudit qui vous fait trois enfants que
vous pendez comme ça à l'aisedrement
3 en trois ans comme une poule pond des
œufs
dites-moi non attendez là là l'heure est
grave il vous faisait peur un peu ce
durkan et vous avez peur un peu hein
vous étiez un peu envoûté par lui quand
même il y a quelque chose de compliqué
avec lui
vous avez décidé d'être honnête ça me
fait plaisir
il dormait avec un couteau
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile
je vais vous connaissez une dossier Fred
et donc voilà donc vous avez marre un
jour d'habiter dans cette baraque à 50
bornes de Paris de pas fait pour ça tous
vos potes et vos copines vous disent
qu'est-ce que tu fais là-bas donc vous
finissez par revenir et là votre
carrière redémarre et vous faites ce
film merveilleux qui est la Fiancée du
Pirate et ensuite vous faites la maman
et la [ __ ] et là vous évidemment tout
le monde est sur le cul parce qu'on
attend que vous fassiez la [ __ ] et
vous faites la maman voilà on a dit
et puis après vous faites de nombreux
films qu'on va pas tous citer dans les
fronter qui vous a rapporté un César on
l'a dit tout à l'heure et un jour et là
j'en arrive à vous mesdemoiselles un
jour vous découvrez le théâtre vous
aussi c'est-à-dire qu'un Joal monte vous
montez sur une sur une scène de théâtre
et vous avez une espèce de sensation
comme ça complètement inédite pour vous
une exaltation extraordinaire et vous
dites c'est comme au cinéma quand j'ai
commencé qu'on disait moteur
non j'ai pas dit ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je suis doux comme un Agnelet
comme il vient de chanter Fernandel
allez-y vous avez dit quoi vous avez je
me souviens très bien je me suis dit
j'ai fait un vœu comme ça une sorte
d'élan mystiques un peu disons j'étais
derrière je l'ai juste passé pour jouer
cette comtesse sanglante donc qui était
le premier rôle j'ai dit je veux bien ne
plus jamais faire de cinéma si je peux
toujours perdre du théâtre
et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
le 25 janvier 2002
vous allez jouer donc Léo de Patrick
lunant au Petit Théâtre de Paris alors
comment es-tu tête vous allez faire le
pitch
alors la situation au début de la pièce
c'est un jeune homme qui est dans une
sorte de studio d'enregistrement qui
tourne en rond on sent qu'il attend
qu'il est angoissé
et l'interphone sonne il dit c'est toi
Pierre et la réponse non ce n'est pas
pierre c'est maman c'est moi maman et
donc j'arrive là c'est mon fils je ne
l'ai pas vu depuis 10 ans
lui est ravagé parce que il est dans un
grand grand chagrin d'amour
et moi je viens lui dire que je sais
qu'il est [ __ ] et ces deux personnes qui
se
qui s'accroche très très très fort
là-dessus mais en même temps ça permet
d'ouvrir plein de tiroirs il se parlent
ils se parlent c'est un grand film sur
en fait il est homosexuel mais il
pourrait être autre chose c'est une mère
et un fils et ça va loin quoi c'est très
beau
c'est écrit par Patrick lunon et c'est
aux petit théâtres de Paris il y a aussi
une jeune fille qui est donc la fiancée
du fils qui donne un espoir à la mer
mais en fait ça va être un mariage blanc
parce qu'elle est sri lankaise et qu'il
faut qu'elle ait des papiers c'est comme
ça pour qu'elle voilà c'est l'histoire
de ce film de cette pièce merci
[Applaudissements]
avec la forme est-ce que Méline peut
apporter les accessoires s'il vous plaît
on va faire une interview croyance
[Musique]
et je voulais
que Méline apporte quelques accessoires
pour cette interview de croyance
très bien c'est parfait Didier s'il te
plaît
[Musique]
est-ce que vous croyez
en Dieu
dans la pièce je dis mais pourquoi
j'invoque Dieu je suis folle je ne crois
rien mais si je crois en la vie je crois
en la vie voilà est-ce que croyez en
vous
je fais avec
est-ce que vous croyez aux anges
gardiens oui aux anges tout court oui
gardien pas gardien
j'ai cru après je n'y ai plus cru et
j'ai recrut ça peut peut-être me revenir
encore dessus
peut-être
ou d'autres
oui
[Musique]
heureusement est-ce que vous croyez à la
réincarnation
moi je crois qu'on a plusieurs vies déjà
dans sa vie on meurt c'est une très
bonne réponse
[Musique]
est-ce que vous croyez à la fidélité
maintenant oui
à cause de quoi
cela
est-ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour
un amour sans sexe
ouais
ça tombe sur vous Muriel
ça marche
pas vous êtes la nièce de Michel Drucker
je vais pas faire est-ce que est-ce que
là j'ai oublié cette question est-ce que
vous croyez qu'on peut faire l'amour 5
fois de suite
[Applaudissements]
oui Muriel je trouverai le cela j'aime
pas très beaucoup les chiffres impairs
donc je serai plutôt pour 6 très bien
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu